the Joe Rogan experience there's um you
know about the Sunderbans in India yes
that's a crazy place crazy I I did a bit
about that in my act as well about in
2009 my Comedy Central special we're
over a period of 200 years they think
somewhere in the neighborhood of 300,000
people have been killed by Tigers and
the sinaitic bands isn't that nuts I
mean it's just like that that number
it's all it's unfathomable there's a
story that I talked about in my in that
set where there was a boat filled with
five guys and one tiger swam out to the
boat killed a guy dragged his body to
shore jump back in the water swam out to
the boat there was another guy did it
with three different guys until he got
tired of killing people that's insane
killed three people in a boat of five so
there's two guys lost three instal
[ __ ] their pants
they swim yeah oh yeah this is crazy and
what's crazy about the sunder Barnes too
is there's saltwater crocodiles there's
Tigers there's bear I mean there's
elephants
yeah there's Asiatic Sunbear there it's
just like it's just got it's this crazy
little habitat and I know a couple
photographers that have been in there
and they're like you don't see anything
it's like huge tall Tufts of grass you
know everything can hide perfectly and
it's all there and you just don't see it
coming oh [ __ ]
and bunch of people that are living in
these huts and yes villages they have no
protection but you said something
earlier today about how your friend
projected the wolf howl into the my
friend that guy in that oh sorry now
that we're both expert but what I I love
I find that those non-conflict
mitigations are going to be the wave of
the future right using technology to
come up with bio controls like a wolf
growl to other wolves or you know an
alarming sound or a smell that animals
don't want to interfere because of
territories I think that stuff's
fascinating it is yeah I agree
yeah it really is interesting and I
think one of the cool things about all
this wildlife is that if we handle it
correctly we can make sure that these
things are sustainable and they stay
around we can we can still be
like just marvel at their presence yeah
and and you know this it's it is
possible to keep wolves here yeah it's
possible to keep grizzly bears here it's
possible to keep all these things here
and we really really really really
should yeah because if you go back and
taught me how amazing would it be if we
could go back in time and see
saber-tooth Tigers like incredible to be
able to see some of these animals that
you only see depictions of where you see
skulls of you know that were caught in
the La Brea Tar Pits or something like
we have those things right now we hide
now a lot of them and we can save them
and we have the the knowledge the power
the technology the tools the finance we
have all the pieces of the puzzle to
make it work well I think that's one of
the really cool things about what you do
is you you broadcast all this stuff and
you let people know and you have a big
signal and you show people all this cool
stuff like that tortoise that you found
or like all these other different
animals and you let people know like
this is this is interesting this is
exciting this is and it's something that
it's like it's in our DNA to be
fascinated by other life-forms right and
it's worth saving yeah no it's like like
we don't want to be sitting here you're
our great-grandkids Joe sitting at the
same table you know a hundred years from
now going man imagine if we could have
seen a grizzly bear yeah you know like
we don't want that well we still have
them here in California it's an ARFF
state flag it's in our flag the golden
grizzly yeah but there's not a single
one left now there's they killed all
those [ __ ] yeah possibly
I don't want to get down a weird rabbit
hole here possibly in Mexico the silver
is easily bear in the high high Mexican
Sierras what's on going reports of
Grizzlies so the same species that would
have been here right that hung out in
the Sierras traveling all the way down
into the Sierra Madres of Mexico and
then in these what they call sky islands
if you're familiar with that term I'll
explain in a second these islands of
isolated habitat up in the sky where
they get more rainfall and everything
else there's there's big tracts of
private land down there in Mexico where
a couple of these farmers are like
something's killing my cattle and it's
not a mountain lion and it could
potentially be like half a dozen Mexican
grizzly bears couldn't be getting
Jaguars though could be but they're
saying it's not cats there's like
reported sightings of seeing bears real
and if you look up the Mexican grizzly
bear
it was declared extinct 20 years before
the another one was killed so like now
they're gone they're declared extinct
then 20 years later some guy shoots one
Google Mexican grizzly bear I need to
see this
so which set I'm trying to find
something like this just shows pictures
of grizzly bears if so I'm trying to
find like so you can add the words
silver in my silver do they think it's
just the fur color oh so they have like
a silvery color to them like Oh hard to
tell what those are real
stuffy that's in Chicago but they're
from Mexico yeah so what year is this
that's probably world fair time I don't
know Wow 99 that says but take a look at
winter the last one was killed and then
if you if you can find it see where it
says they were extinct and it's many
many years later on parade of some sort
whoa look at that [ __ ] 1960 1960s yeah
interesting so it might be possible that
that thing is still alive somewhere
there are reports floating in and I mean
the 60s it's not long ago right so you
know there's reports that on these giant
tracts of private land up in these
mountains there's potentially a very
small population of Mexican grizzly
bears Wow which I think's fascinating
and it's one of those things that I
don't think it's like so crazy I don't
think anybody's gone and looked you know
what I mean like if some rancher who
owns half a million acres in Mexico is
like yeah I've got a bear killing my
cows it's like sure you do right but
maybe he does like who's gone to
investigate up in the high mountain peak
areas of this million acre ranch well
there's not supposed to be grizzly bears
in Colorado but my friend Adam Greentree
who is a very experienced outdoorsman he
was hunting in the San Juan Mountains
and he got a grizzly bear filmed Noah on
camera he's looking at it through a
scope and he documented it on his
Instagram page and he's like that is a
[ __ ] grizzly well there's a and
there's sightings of them from the path
that was
when he was getting chased by one but
that was in I believe that was in either
Idaho or Wyoming places were they're
known about grizzly bears his sighting
of this is when he's like he's holding
up a gun and a female kept bluff
charging him see her standing there in
the background oh yeah she's not happy
not happy
[ __ ] wasn't his gun not right it wasn't
no his gun he had the wrong caliber
bullet and his gun so it didn't really
load all the way into the pistol and he
didn't know that until after this
altercation so even if he had like
pulled the trigger nothing would've
happened right no bueno
but she bluffed charged him she got
within like 30 feet a couple of times
[Applause]